I always say little big planet is what
are the hardest games to categorize in
the world you've got a comprehensive
what you've got a platform game you can
play with up to four players which is
great loads of fun but uniquely that
platform game is made with a toolset
that we supply with again so it's a game
making tool and the adventure that we
give you is just an example of the kind
of things that you can yourself make the
big feature of little big planet is that
you choose how you want to play that
game you know there are lots of games
where it's very rigid you know he plays
sports game you playing football gotta
play football the great thing about
littlebigplanet as far as I'm concerned
is that really you get to choose what
you want to do a creative perspective
it's not just a passive experience so
you're not just being entertained by
what we've made the whole time our job
is to inspire you to get into create
mode and start making your own stuff so
we've really gone out of our way to make
the adventure as thrilling as possible
and a real showcase all the tools that
we've added megatons it exists the live
streaming feature of ps4 is going to be
a really big deal for a little big
planet and the reason i think that is
that it is the best way to teach someone
to create you can possibly have if
you've got a good creator who's just SAT
and create mode put the live stream up
on twitch at is sitting there building
something and talking you through how
you can make that thing that's going to
encourage so many more creators and it
gives us a great opportunity for
teaching people how we made this game
and again it's just another great way of
hopefully getting more people into the
create mode by seeing actually how
doable this easier how easy this can be
ps4 has done some wonders as far as the
the graphics department goes for us on
the game 1080p all of the textures have
been appraised they look fantastic got
new lighting new materials new effects
the snow dust fog we've linked in to the
PlayStation 4 video suite and allows you
to create trailers for your content and
push that up onto air we peed on me so
when people are browsing the community
screen they're not just going to be
seeing the level badge and description
anymore
there will be a 30 second trailer
there'll be photos you know it's going
to look like a professionally made thing
and that's our doesn't game-changing for
me I think that makes that makes all of
that stuff feel much more professional
it's great we've made the game a lot
deeper the original game was essentially
jumping up and down and he had a
playable depth of about three layers we
expanded that to 16 allows designers
developers creators ability to make
entirely new elements of gameplay
popping back and forth and through the
screen I'm an artistic side they can
build their own backgrounds now and drop
them in there where they weren't able to
do that in the past and they'll be
planet 3 we put quite a lot of focus on
who you're playing and how you're
playing and not so much on you know we
already have all those great level talks
may origin still work rather than just
playing a sack boy you can have three
new playable characters to go with SAT
boy which opens up a whole new style of
gameplay that coexists with Sackboy in
craft world so we came up with toggle
odd sock and swoop and we felt that
releasing this to a hugely tanta
community would mean you're going to
start seeing a whole new style of
content coming out we have a bunch of
stuff which allows you to change the way
that sack boy works so that you can make
him run faster all making swim or change
his animation style can then do that to
the new playable characters as well and
make your own game we've opened the
doors up to our advanced users to give
them more control over elements of game
making that they never had before they
can now control a lot of the animations
on their characters so they have a new
arsenal of characters that can drop into
their levels build all sorts of
different gameplay probably the coolest
thing so far in Little Big Planet 3 is
the top-down platformer level it uses
pretty much everyone Anthony
littlebigplanet tools which is what's
cool about it from it usually didn't go
wow it's quite a technical achievement
something never would have been able to
have been done in any of the previous
games
backwards compatibility has always kind
of been priority number one everything
from the very beginning of the Little
Big Planet franchise is still there so
we have this enormous world of creations
that is always relevant I think we've
got pretty much 100 new tools in this
game not only do you have the eight
million levels that have already been
made but you were going to have a whole
new type of level which has never been
in doable before because of the power
that we've added to the create feature
I hope the people at home find little
big planet 3 opening up that they can
play it hello thing I think what's great
for anybody playing mystery planet is
that they get a great high quality game
on disk that we've made and then they'll
get years of new content coming in
day-by-day week-by-week of really high
quality levels made by the community
really fun to play through the game to
collect the prizes to collect all the
stickers and the decorations and those
things take them back to the editor and
see what you can make with them because
no two creations are ever the same and
there's been millions and millions of
them and I know we've had millions of
people that have felt that way about
about the game and about being able to
create and just make their own things
close them